why did you do I'm a teacher I'm trying
to make it on the PGA Tour's for the
316th quartermaster company now an under
coverage on your lies are your life
Graceland a new original series
premieres Thursday June 6 to 10 on USA
how you doing guys really quickly I want
to tell you guys about something that's
gonna be going on on my channel for the
years to come you see I've joined an
independent Network on YouTube called
full screen along with a lot of other of
my movie reviewer buddies who've also
joined as well basically a couple times
a month we rather than allowing YouTube
to choose some sort of pre-roll or
something for you to watch that they
think you'd be interested in seeing I
actually get to show you a brief little
advertisement for something that I'm
actually interested in and I get to
voice over it rather than YouTube doing
it for me this is something that
fullscreen has allowed me to do and some
other people who have joined the network
as well and it's pretty cool for me to
be able to do that there's a show coming
out soon Thursday June 6th on USA
Network 10 9:00 p.m. central it's called
Graceland and a lot of you guys have
asked me if I'm going to ever do
television reviews because it's
something that a lot of other reviewers
do and it's something that I am semi
interested in even though there's so
much TV out there and I don't really
have that much experience well it's an
annotation if you guys want to check
that out I am semi interested in
actually watching that show and that's
why I wanted to tell you guys about it
and I've chosen that as a thing that I
can tell you guys about in the future
you'll see me do this maybe a couple
times a month it doesn't mean that I'm a
sellout it just means that I get to
choose my own advertisement that I can
share with you guys rather than allowing
YouTube to show you something about I
don't know Mother's Day bras
my name is Chris Stockman I believe in a
balanced healthy diet
as well as feeding my fish every morning
each morning I do as many crunches as I
can I can do 25 now I'm also sure to do
as many homoerotic poses as possible
that really don't do anything to
strengthen my physique I just like doing
it there is an idea of a Chris Stockman
an elusive movie lover who square with
let's just review the movie now for my
review of American Psycho I had to dress
up because Patrick Bateman will probably
find me and kill me if I'm not in my
nicest threads yes
American Psycho is one of my all-time
favorite movies it's a film that is so
different and original that it's really
difficult to really explain this to
someone without just showing it to them
in fact I recently showed it to a friend
of mine and beforehand I was like how do
I set him up for this what do I say and
there really is only one thing I think
you really should know going into this
movie this is supposed to be a dark
comedy this movie is not meant to be
taken 100% seriously because if you view
this as a straight 100% dramatic
thriller you're gonna think everyone
sucks at acting and you're not gonna get
it
American Psycho is a movie about a guy
named Patrick Bateman he is the most
narcissistic full of himself businessman
you could ever run into this movie takes
place in the late 80s you get a lot of
shots where he's wearing like the
old-style headphones listening to Huey
Lewis and the news Phil Collins Whitney
Houston and he likes to go on long
monologues explaining the bands or
singers various intricacies to people
right before he kills them because
that's what he likes to do at night this
man is a bloodthirsty serial killer who
likes to go around finding random people
to take out when the sun goes down and
this new addiction that he has is
starting to seep into his everyday life
and the way this film depicts that
through bales performance and mary
herons great direction is so cool to
watch because as the film starts you
start to get these little subtle hints
that some of the things she's doing at
night our murderous if you going to this
movie not really knowing much about the
plot you'll like it even more because as
movie starts from scene to scene you see
him get this look on his face as the
night draws to a close and the next
scene he has his sheets at the
laundromat and he's trying to get some
kind of stain out of it and you're not
exactly sure what that stain is from but
it looks like blood and as the film
progresses you start to see more and
more of his private life at night
and it becomes increasingly more
entertaining and hilarious as he tries
to keep this secret from everyday people
but you also get a great look and
commentary at the narcissism and
selfishness of these types of people
Christian Bale in this movie honestly
gives an oscar-worthy performance his
performance in this movie is so friggin
fantastic there are so many quotable
lines in this movie - it's that great
scene where he's got Paul Allen played
very well by Jared Leto in his apartment
and Paul Allen's like hey man why do you
got like sections of this style column
all over your floor do you have like a
little little dog like a Chow or
something no Alan is that a raincoat yes
it is I'm sorry you're just not terribly
important to me I have to return some
videotapes do you like Phil Collins
let's see Paul Allen's card look at that
subtle off-white coloring the tasteful
thickness on it oh my god it even has
watermark American Psycho is a movie
that is filled with so many great quotes
that I can actually use him in everyday
life to answer people's questions and
they're like what are you talking about
and that's because this movie isn't
really as well-known as I think it
should be it's kind of a cult hit but
the people who love it really spread the
love of this movie marry herons
direction has a great crispness to it
she has a great use of focus and a lot
of her angles obscure and imply violence
that would have become exploitative if
she just showed it and I really like the
way that she handled certain scenes in
this movie because it's very easy as you
read this script to think wow if this
isn't made just right this is going to
come off really stupid I mean Christian
Bale running through a hallway but naked
wearing sneakers holding a chainsaw
laughing that could easily come off so
so bad but the way that it's acted
written and directed made everything
just right because it has a great dark
comic tone to it and it's really
reflected well in the way the film shows
that he's a serial killer at night but
this narcissistic businessman by day his
actions by day are extremely similar to
the way he is at night completely
selfish in every way 100% concerned with
only whatever he wants and his desires
must be fulfilled it's just that at
night he's more violent about it and I
really like the way the film portrays
that the use of music and Batemans long
analogues about it was also really great
to portray that 80's lifestyle as well
and I love the narration in this movie
as well because narration can a lot of
times be used as a crutch a way for a
filmmaker to explain something that
don't really know how to portray
visually to the audience so hey we'll
just have the main character say it
through narration but here the narration
in American Psycho is so interesting and
so well written that I can't really
imagine the movie without it and it
doesn't come off as needless exposition
it really feels like it's required to be
there to grow and strengthen the
character Patrick Bateman Willem Dafoe
is also in this movie to kind of provide
some extra suspense he's a detective who
is looking for whoever's murdering these
various people and he has a lot of
meetings with Patrick Bateman in the
movie and add some extra suspense to the
movie and he's of course very good as
Willem Dafoe typically is really all the
actors in this movie shine and the movie
looks incredible and it's written very
well and has a great wit and commentary
on the way business people are and
narcissistic and selfish people are but
it also has a really great underlying
hint of what exactly is fact and fiction
in this movie is some of this in his
head is some of it not in his head I
really think the film delves into that
very beautifully and it gives the viewer
that needed questioning like you're
seeing there like did I just see that is
that real is that fake what's going like
it really makes you kind of feel as if
you're in the mind of Patrick Bateman
which is a dangerous place to be but it
allows you to observe it from afar and
also feel connected to it it's a really
hard film to explain you really just
have to see this movie if you haven't
seen it I strongly suggested American
Psycho is one of my favorite movies and
I'm going to give it an A+
so guys I'll be back with more reviews
for my favorite movies very soon it's a
cool way for me to be able to give you
guys an idea of the type of films that
molded me into the movie reviewer that I
am today and I can't wait to see more
films that continue to mould and change
my thoughts on film I look forward to
doing that with you guys watching as
well thanks as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes